Голова Верховної Ради запізнився на
погоджувальну раду можливо він був з
опзж на пам'ятниках в цей час і не чув
що там піднімалося питання необхідності
поставити Постанову номер 10 391 щодо
відкликання пані безуглої з посади
заступниці голови комітету нацбезпеки
оборони нагадаємо що перші підписи на
цій постанові також представники фракції
слуга народу і тому ми в рамках єдності
парламентської вимагаємо від голови
Верховної Ради поставити зараз на
пленарне засідання постанову про
відкликання пані безуглої з голови
заступника голови комітету нацбезпеки і
оборони і прошу вас пане голово не
дискредитувати фракцію європейська
Солідарність давати точну інформацію ми
піднімали це питання на погоджуванні в
понеділок особисто Артур Герасимов